This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Pasta is one of the greatest foods ever invented, but it can get a little predictable, especially the pasta dishes we make for ourselves. Whether it's another night of spaghetti, or a slightly jazzed up fettuccine Alfredo, it can get boring making the same dish over and over. Our friend Dan Patchman took note of this conundrum and decided to kickstart a pasta revolution. I am the creator and host of the Sporkful Food Podcast, the inventor of the Cascatelli pasta shape
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。面食是有史以来最伟大的发明之一，但它有时会变得有点刻板，尤其是我们自己做的那些意面。无论是又一个吃意大利面（spaghetti）的夜晚，还是稍微花哨一点的奶油宽面（f fettuccine Alfredo），一遍又一遍地做同一道菜确实会让人感到无聊。我们的朋友丹·帕什曼注意到了这个困惑，并决定发起一场意面革命。我是美食播客《Sporkful》的创作者兼主持人、Cascatelli 意面形状的发明者，
and author of the new cookbook, Anything's Possible. For those who aren't familiar with the pasta shape that Dan created, it's called Cascatelli. Dan based the creation of Cascatelli on three metrics. First, there's fork ability, which is how easy it is to get onto your fork. Second is sauce ability. How readily does the sauce adhere to the shape? And finally, there's tooth sink ability. That's one word, which is how satisfying it is to sink your
也是新食谱《一切皆有可能》（Anything's Possible）的作者。对于那些不熟悉丹所创造的意面形状的人来说，它叫做 Cascatelli。丹基于三个指标来设计 Cascatelli。首先是叉子附着度，也就是用叉子叉起来有多容易。其次是酱汁吸附度，酱汁能多好地附着在面形上？最后是牙齿嵌入感，这是一个词，指的是用牙齿咬下去有多满足。
teeth into. I set out to invent a new shape of pasta that would hopefully be effective at all three of my metrics and it took three years and a lot of setbacks. It was much harder than I anticipated and I got a lot of door slammed in my face. But the end result was the shape called cascatelli, which has these sort of two parallel ruffles that protrude from the main body of it. It's a short shape and the sauce goes in between the ruffles. It holds a lot of sauce. It's got a lot of interesting textures and it succeeded beyond my wildest dreams. It's now in stores across the country and it succeeded beyond my wildest dreams. It's now in stores across the country, which is still bananas to me.
我着手发明一种新的意面形状，希望它能在我的这三个指标上都表现出色，这花了我三年时间，经历了很多挫折。它比我预期的要难得多，我也吃了许多闭门羹。但最终的成果就是这种名为 cascatelli 的形状，它的主体上突出了两道平行的花边。它是一种短面，酱汁会卡在花边之间。它能挂住很多酱汁。它有着许多有趣的质感，它的成功超出了我最疯狂的梦想。它现在在全国各地的商店里都能买到，这对我来说简直太疯狂了。
I still buy it in the store even though I don't have to because I get so excited when I see it there. It was named one of Time Magazine's best inventions of the year. It was on the cover of Time Magazine. Yeah. I mean, well, it's a little weird to be in your forties and already know that you probably never gonna top
我还是会在商店里买它，尽管我其实不需要买，因为我在那儿看到它时总是兴奋不已。它被《时代》杂志评为年度最佳发明之一。它还上了《时代》杂志的封面。是的。我的意思是，好吧，年过四十却已经知道自己可能再也无法超越刚刚做出的成就，这种感觉有点诡异。但你知道的，以这种成就闻名总好过其他事。发明一种意面形状，这挺不错的。Cascatelli 的诞生过程被记录在《Sporkful》的“不可能的任务”系列中，你可以在节目简介中找到链接。但这不是丹今天来这里的真正原因。自从丹发明的意面形状走红、丹的意面梦想成真以来，
whatever it is you just did. But you know, there are worse things to be known for. It's pretty good, inventing a pasta shape. The creation of Cascatelli is documented in the Sporkful's Mission Impossible series, which you can find a link to in the show notes. But that is not why Dan is here today. Ever since Dan's pasta shape went viral, and Dan's pasta dreams came true,
一个意想不到的新问题出现了。嗯，问题在于我不断收到来自全国各地乃至世界各地的照片。其中 75% 的照片都是 Cascatelli 搭配番茄酱、肉酱、或是通心粉加奶酪。我的意思是，也许有几个派对动物会做青酱。这范围非常窄，种类极其单一。这总让我感到有点难过，
a new unexpected problem emerged. Well, the problem was that I'm getting photo after photo from all over the country and all over the world. And 75% of the photos are Cascatelli with tomato sauce, meat sauce, mac and cheese. I mean, maybe a couple of party animals might make pesto. It was very, the range was very narrow. It just generally made me a little sad
因为我觉得我们在意面上能放的东西远不止这些。这让我意识到，连我自己也陷入了红酱的窠臼。我只是想向其他人以及我自己证明，我们可以而且应该在意面上放更多样的东西。所以，我就是在那个时候萌生了写一本食谱的想法。
because I just felt like there's so much more we can be putting on pasta. And it made me realize even for myself, like I had fallen into a red sauce rut. I just wanted to show other people and myself that there's a lot more that we can and should be putting on our pasta. So that's when I had the idea for a cookbook.
那本食谱的名字叫《一切皆有可能：面向爱好酱汁之人的 81 道创意意面食谱》（Anything's Possible, 81 Inventive Pasta Recipes for Saucy People），这是一个很棒的名字。它几周前刚出版，跟你对一本意面食谱的期望有些不同。我着手尝试写一本完全不包含传统意大利面酱食谱的食谱。里面没有玛格丽塔红酱（marinara）的食谱。没有波洛尼亚肉酱（bolognese）。没有朴素的奶酪黑胡椒意面（cacio e pepe）或卡宴培根蛋面（carbonara），这些都没有。我并不是反对这些菜肴，我只是觉得这个世界不需要
That cookbook's name is Anything's Possible, 81 Inventive Pasta Recipes for Saucy People, which is a great title. It came out a few weeks ago, and it's a bit different than what you'd expect from a pasta cookbook. I set out to try to write a cookbook that would have no traditional Italian pasta sauce recipes in it. There is no recipe for marinara. There's no bolognese. There's no plain old cacci e pepe or carbonara, none of those, I'm not against those dishes, I just feel like the world didn't need
另一本包含这些传统食谱的书了。所以这真的是我的使命：一本不包含每个人都知道的那些传统基础酱汁的意面酱食谱。人们会在你的书里找到什么样的食谱呢？首先，我们远远走出了意大利菜的框架，从我深爱并在自己家里烹饪的许多不同菜系和食材中汲取灵感。
another recipe for those. So that was really my mission, was a cookbook of pasta sauces with none of the traditional basic ones that everyone knows. What kind of recipes will people find in your book? So first off, we're pushing far beyond Italian cuisine to take inspiration from the many cuisines, ingredients that I love and cook with in my own home.
这意味着加入了辣椒脆的奶酪黑胡椒面、泡菜卡宴培根蛋面、基玛波洛尼亚肉酱（将印度经典香料碎肉菜基玛与波洛尼亚肉酱完美结合）。书中还有一道烤洋蓟配渍柠檬酱的菜，经典的意大利做法是洋蓟加柠檬，他们通常用柠檬汁。而我们用的是渍柠檬，
So that means cacio e pepe with chili crisp, kimchi carbonara, quema bolognese, the great Indian spiced ground meat dish quema mashed up with bolognese. There's a dish for a roasted artichoke and preserved lemon sauce, which is like classic Italian thing is artichokes and lemon. They would do lemon juice. Instead, we're doing preserved lemon, which is like classic Italian thing is artichokes and lemon. They would do lemon juice. Instead of we're doing preserved lemon, which is North African Middle Eastern ingredients, adds more savoriness.
这是一种北非和中东地区的食材，能增添更多鲜味。所以很多时候，这并不是要去发明什么异想天开的东西，而只是拿走你熟悉的东西，稍微调整一下，让它变得焕然一新。《Sporkful》播客关于《一切皆有可能》创作过程的四集系列节目涵盖了这本食谱设计的方方面面。从食谱的设计、食物的照片，
So oftentimes it's not inventing something that's so out of left field. That's just taking something that you know and tweaking it a little bit to make it new and different. The Sporkful podcast four part series about the making of anything's possible covers all aspects of the design of the cookbook. From the design of the recipes, to photos of the food,
到食谱中使用的语言背后的思考。这里面有无数需要做出的决定。我确信 99PI 的听众可能比普通人更懂得欣赏食谱的设计，但有些事情是我以前从未充分考虑过、而你却不得不去思考的，比如：好吧，你要展示这道菜。现在听着，把食物拍得看起来很好吃其实并不需要多少天赋，对吧？
to the thought behind the language used in the recipes. There are a million decisions to be made. I'm sure that 99PI listeners probably are more attuned to the design of a cookbook than the average person, but the things that I never fully considered that you have to think about, things like, all right, you're gonna depict this dish. Now look, it actually doesn't require a ton of talent
打开 Instagram，很多人都在这么做。但难的是以一种能够向人们传达更多关于食物背后故事以及写书之人的方式来呈现一道菜。这真是一门手艺。所以这些细节包括：
to make food look delicious, okay? Like turn on Instagram, a lot of people are doing it. But what is difficult is to present a dish in a way that tells you something more about the story behind the food and the person who has written this book. And that is a real craft. And so it's things like,
好吧，这里有一盘美味的食物，它装在什么样盘子里？旁边有酒杯吗？有一品脱啤酒吗？是精美的银制餐具吗？餐具和餐位摆放得严丝合缝，还是有点歪斜？食物被咬了一口吗？
okay, there's a plate of delicious food, what kind of plate is it on? Is it a wine glass? Is it a pint of beer? Is it fancy silverware? Is the silverware and the place setting set just so, or is it a bit askew? Has a bite been taken out of the food?
桌上有面包屑吗？你看，我希望我的书呈现出一种充满生活气息、真实的感觉。所以我希望这里有一张揉成一团的餐巾纸。我希望看到一只手伸过来抓点什么。我希望看到食物被咬过一口。因为我的风格是平易近人的。我不是什么高级餐厅的大厨。
Are there crumbs on the table? See, I wanted the look of my book to feel lived in and real. So I wanted crumpled up napkin here. I wanted a hand coming in and grabbing something. I wanted a bite taken out. Because my style is accessible. I'm not a fancy chef.
我不想让书里的照片看起来像四季酒店。我希望它看起来就像是在你家里一样。我的意思是，为了让照片看起来就像是一个普通人随手撒下这些面包屑一样，实际上有专人用镊子和画笔把面包屑摆得恰到好处。所以在我们系列的第四集里，你会听到很多这样煞费苦心的工作。所以，当你考虑这些不同的创意意面食谱时，你的其中一个灵感来源是，
I didn't want it to look like the Four Seasons in the book. I wanted to look like this could be your house. I mean, to make a photo look like a regular person just sprinkled these crumbs willy nilly, I mean, there are people with tweezers and paint brushes arranging the crumbs just so. So you hear a lot of that painstaking work in episode four of our series. So when you were thinking about these different creative pasta recipes, one of your sources of
你知道的，那些没有流传开来、也没有装进我们货架上各种罐头里的意大利食谱。聊聊这个，以及是什么促使你去意大利做实地调研的，除了这本身就是一个绝佳的公费旅游借口之外——哥们儿，我真的是向你致敬。对，对。你是说我可以为了工作去意大利？
inspiration was, you know, some of the Italian recipes that didn't make it over and spread through jars all across our shelves. Talk about that and, like, what led you to go to Italy to do research, other than the fact that that's such a great scam, man. I just, I, hats off. Right, right. You mean I can go to Italy for work?
好吧。所以我想去意大利，因为我可以，呃……但同时，是的，我想在最初的研究中重点介绍一些我在美国不为人知的、鲜为人知的意大利面食，它们位于美国游客不常涉足的意大利地区。其中一道叫做萨西纳意大利面（spaghetti alla sassina）。它是在意大利靴子脚跟东南部的一个叫巴里（Bari）的城市发明的。这是将意大利面放入辛辣的番茄酱中烹煮，
Okay. So I wanted to go to Italy because I could, eh. But also, yes, I wanted to feature some obscure Italian pasta dishes that I came across in my initial research that are not known in America, in regions of Italy that are not often traveled by tourists from the US. And so one of them is called spaghetti alla sassina. It was invented in a city called Bari in the southeastern corner in the heel of the boot of Italy. That's this spaghetti cooked in a spicy tomato sauce
直到酱汁几乎变成糊状，然后继续用平底锅煎，直到意大利面有些地方烤焦酥脆，有些地方金黄酥脆，而在另一部分又依然保持着嚼劲。你得到了所有这些不同且令人难以置信的质感。这太惊艳了，但你在巴里之外是吃不到的。不过我也想从更宏观的角度来看看
until the sauce almost turns to a paste and you keep pan frying it until the pasta turns charred and crispy crunchy in parts, golden brown and crispy in other parts and yet still chewy in a third section of parts. You get all these different incredible textures. It's phenomenal, but you can't get it outside Bari. But I also wanted to kind of get a bigger picture view
意大利的意面文化，你知道的，因为听着，当我发明 cascatelli 时，人们总是问我：“意大利人怎么看？他们一定在对你挥拳相向吧。”当我开始着手写这本食谱时，也有类似的问题：“意大利人会怎么说？”我知道有一种刻板印象，我认为在某种程度上这也算是一种漫画式的夸张，
of Italian pasta culture, you know, because look, when I invented cascatelli, people always ask me, what do the Italians think? They must be shaking their fist at you. And when I started working on the cookbook, similar question, what are the Italians gonna say? And I know that there is this sort of stereotype, I think to some degree it's a bit of a caricature
那就是意大利人痛恨对传统的任何偏离，尽管你可能看到街对面两位老奶奶做同一道菜的做法都不一样。我当时对意大利食物是否真的像那些刻板印象所描绘的那样一成不变持怀疑态度。所以我决定亲自去意大利一探究竟。
of these, you know, of Italians hating any's a bit of a caricature of these Italians hating any variation from tradition, even though you could have two grandmas across the street from each other who cook the same dish differently. I was skeptical that Italian food was as set in stone as the people behind that caricature would have you believe. And so I decided to try to go to Italy to see for myself.
而你发现的——这也是我们接下来要播放的那一集——不仅是意大利美食极具可塑性，而且我们心目中那些被出口到美国的“意大利菜”，其历史其实近得惊人。这简直太疯狂了。我的下巴到现在还合不拢呢。
And what you found, and this is the episode that we're gonna play, is that not only is Italian food cuisine very mutable, it's kind of mind-blowingly recent, the things that we think of as Italian food that has been exported to the US. It's really kind of nuts. My jaw's sort of still on the floor.
首先，意大利成为一个国家只有大约 150 年的历史。没错。好吧。是的，当然，该地区有着更为久远的历史，但它大约在 150 年前才实现统一，并且很长一段时间以来，这里依然是一个极具地方特色且略显分裂的地方。因此，“自古以来就有一种固定做法”这种想法根本站不住脚。非常感谢你，丹。
First of all, Italy only became a country about 150 years ago. Right. Okay. Yes, of course, there's's sort of still on the floor. First of all, Italy only became a country about 150 years ago. Right. Okay. Yes, of course, there's a lot of history in the region that goes back much further, but it was only unified about 150 years ago for a long time. And it's still a very regional place and somewhat fractious. And so the idea that there was one way to do things, you know, since the dawn of time, it just doesn't add up. Thanks so much, Dan.
接下来我们要播放这期节目。谢谢罗曼。今天，我们将为您带来《一切皆有可能》系列的第二集，丹·帕什曼踏上了前往意大利的旅程。这是一集非常精彩的节目。这是一个非常有趣的项目。《一切皆有可能》的所有四集
And we're going to play the episode. Thanks, Roman. Today, we're bringing you the second episode of the Anything's Possible series, where Dan Pashman embarks on a trip to Italy. It is a great episode. It is a really fun project. All four episodes of Anything's Possible
现在都可以在 The Sporkful 收听。《一切皆有可能》食谱现已在各大书店有售。如果你想回听 Cascatelli 是如何诞生的，节目简介中附有“不可能的任务”系列的链接。以下是丹·帕什曼带来的内容。在上一期《一切皆有可能》中。作为一个外来者去接触一种菜系的人，可能会觉得没有必要对传统唯命是从。我觉得你完全、百分之百地错了。
are available right now from the Sporkville. The Anything's Possible cookbook is available in bookstores now. And if you want to go back and hear how Cascateli came to be, the Mission Impossible series is linked in the show notes. Here's Dan Pashman. Previously on Anything's Possible. People who come to a cuisine as outsiders might feel less beholden to tradition. I think you're absolutely 100% wrong.
好吧。我只是在想，测试所有这些食谱真的让我感到非常开心。简妮，你对整个过程有什么看法？这看起来有太多工作了。我甚至在想：你真的想写这本食谱吗？你到底想要多少个食谱？根据我的图书合同，我必须包含 75 到 100 个食谱。
Okay. I was just thinking about the fact that I am having so much fun testing all these recipes. Janie, what are your thoughts on how does this whole process? It seems like so much work. I'm actually like, do you really want to do this cookbook? How many recipes do you want to have? I'm required by my book contract to have 75 to 100 recipes.
哦，天哪。这是我的第二本书，而我的第一本书根本没人买。如果这次没人买这本书，我就不会有第三次机会了。这里是 The Sporkful。它不是为美食家准备的，而是为吃货准备的。我是丹·帕什曼。每周在我们的节目中，我们对食物魂牵梦绕，借此更深入地了解人。
Oh my god. This is my second book and my first book nobody bought. And if no one buys this book, I'm not going to get a third shot. This is The Spork Full. It's not for foodies, it's for eaters. I'm Dan Pashman. Each week on our show we obsess about food to learn more about people.
这是《101个可能》（Everything's Possible）的第二集，这是一个由四部分组成的系列节目，将为你独家揭秘我的第一本食谱的幕后故事。听完之后，你将彻底改变对食谱的看法。现在，如果你还没听过第一部分，请返回去从头开始听吧。好了，我们切入正题。我们将从上次中断的地方继续。那是 2022 年的春天，我抛开了心中的疑虑，全身心地投入到食谱的研究与开发中。我书中的许多食谱都是我和我的食谱研发人员共同构思出来的。
This is episode two of Anything's Possible, a four-part series giving you the inside story of the making of my first cookbook. By the end, you'll never look at a cookbook the same way again. Now, if you haven't listened to part one yet, please go back and start there. Okay, let's get into it. We'll pick up where we left off. It's the spring of 2022, and I'm pushing aside my doubts and fully immersing myself in recipe research and development. A lot of the recipes in my book will be things that my recipe developers and I come up
但在阅读旧食谱和与在意大利生活过的人交谈时，我也偶然发现了一些鲜为人知的意大利面食，它们看起来非常适合我的书。它们即使在意大利本地，在其特定地区之外也鲜为人知。它们做起来相当简单，而且带有令人惊讶的改良，使其从你见过无数次的那些面食中脱颖而出。但这些菜肴实在太冷门了，以至于在美国很难找到知道怎么做的人。我决定，如果我要把它们做好，就必须去意大利进行一次考察之旅。我女儿艾米莉（Emily）对这个消息的反应是：
with. But in reading through old cookbooks and talking to people who've lived in Italy, I've also come across a few obscure Italian pasta dishes that seem perfect for my book. They're mostly unknown even in Italy outside their specific regions. They're pretty easy to make and they contain surprising twists that really make them stand out from the ones you've seen a million times. But these dishes are so obscure that it's hard to find people in America who know how to make them. I decide that if I'm going to do them right, I have to go on a research trip to Italy. My daughter Emily's response to that news?
每个人都说，哦天哪，意大利的面最好吃；每个人都说，哦天哪，意大利。为什么非得是意大利？意大利到底有什么好的？嗯，最大的好处之一就是我可以在这些菜肴的发源地，品尝由最了解它们的人所烹制的鲜为人知的美味。但除了研究这些菜肴，我这次旅行还有一个更大的目标。你知道的，每个人都在开玩笑说意大利人多么排斥
Everything's like, oh my god, the good pastas in Italy, and everybody's like, oh my god, Italy. Why does it have to be in Italy? What's so great about Italy? Well, one great thing will be that I can taste these little known dishes in the places they're from, cooked by the people who know them best. But in addition to researching these dishes, I have a larger goal for this trip. You know, everyone jokes about how resistant Italians are
任何对传统的偏离。在推出 Cascatelli 时，我遇到的最常见的问题之一就是：“意大利人怎么看？”对于这本食谱，我也可以预料到类似的问题：意大利人会怎么看待我想尝试的想法，比如泡菜卡宴培根蛋面、玛莎拉牛肉通心粉（mac and doll）以及日式香松青酱？显而易见的答案是他们不会喜欢，因为“以前不一直是这么做的吗”。但我在研究中惊讶地发现，我想去意大利了解的其中一道面食，其实是在大约 60 年前才被发明的。
to any deviation from tradition. With Cascatelli, one of the most common questions I got was, what do the Italians think? I could anticipate a similar question with this cookbook. What do Italians think of ideas I want to try like kimchi carbonara, mac and doll, and furikake pesto? The obvious answer is they won't like it, because that's not the way it's always been done. But I was surprised to learn in my research that one of the pasta dishes I want to go to Italy to learn about was actually only invented about 60 years ago.
为意大利面食谱（pasta canon）增添新成员的想法，我以前从未真正想过。我只是理所当然地认为所有的意大利面食谱都源自古代。但这道较新的菜肴让我不禁思考：在一个总是被描绘成复古褐色调的饮食文化中，演变和创新是如何发生的？我的书又在这个过程中扮演什么角色带着这些问题，我登上了飞往意大利的航班。欢迎来到罗马，目前当地的正确时间是 7 点。在 2022 年盛夏，我抵达了罗马。
The notion of a new addition to Italy's pasta canon hadn't really occurred to me. I just assumed all the Italian pasta recipes were from ancient times. But this newer dish made me wonder, how do evolution and innovation happen in a food culture that always seems to be depicted in sepia tones? And where does my book fit into that process? With those questions in mind, I board a flight to Italy. Pleasure to welcome you to Rome, where the correct local time is 7. In the peak of summer 2022, I arrive in Rome.
在我的第一天，体感温度高达 102 华氏度（约 39 摄氏度）。当你走出门外，那种感觉就像……就像一股炼制好的猪颊肉（guanciale）油脂之墙向我们扑面而来。这感觉真是绝了。我将和美食作家凯蒂·帕拉（Katie Parla）一起，在罗马开启“逛吃”模式。她是一个在美国生活、但在意大利已经住了 20 年的美国人。她写过好几本关于意大利美食的食谱，并提供美食导览，她的客户还包括斯坦利·图齐（Stanley Tucci）、安德鲁·齐默恩（Andrew Zimmern）以及阿克申·布朗森（Action Bronson）等上电视节目的名厨。从这里穿过去，因为这样快一点。我们正在走过去。
On my first day, the heat index is 102 degrees. When you walk out the door, it feels like... Like a wall of rendered guanciale fat washing over us. It's really something. I'm about to eat my way across Rome with food writer Katie Parla, an American who's been living in Italy for 20 years. She's written multiple cookbooks about Italian cuisine and gives food tours, including to folks like Stanley Tucci, Andrew Zimmern, and Action Bronson on their TV shows. Cut through here because it's a little bit faster. We're walking through.
我和凯蒂前往吃午饭。路上，她向我解释说，意大利菜具有很强的地域性。有许多菜肴只在一个地方能找到，有时甚至只在一个小镇上才有。从历史上看，罗马一直是少数几种不同烹饪传统交融的地方之一。所以，这里是个探索意大利面食文化如何演变这一宏大问题的好地方。
Katie and I head to lunch. On the way, she explains that Italian food is very regional. There are lots of dishes that are only found in one area and sometimes in only one town. Historically, Rome has been one of the few places where different culinary traditions have mixed. So it's a good place to explore my larger questions of how Italian pasta culture evolves.
Buongiorno，你好，凯蒂，最近怎么样？我们到达了第一站——Piatto Romano 餐厅。这里是个探索意大利面食文化如何演变这一宏大问题的好地方。我们到达了第一站——Piatto Romano 餐厅。我们来这里是因为这里的食物总是极其美味。他们做出的菜肴真正反映了我们所在的地理位置。凯蒂给我们点了三道面食、一份沙拉和一些酒。正是在这家餐厅，一切对我来说都改变了，因为凯蒂抛出了一颗关于意大利面的重磅炸弹：意大利人是从 20 世纪开始才经常吃面食的。
Buongiorno, ciao, Katie, come stai? We arrive at our first stop, Piatto Romano. It's a good place to explore my larger questions of how Italian pasta culture evolves. We arrive at our first stop, Piatto Romano. We're here because the food is always delicious. They do things that really reflect the location that we're in. Katie orders us three pasta dishes, a salad and some wine. And it's at this restaurant where everything changes for me, because Katie drops a pasta bombshell. The 20th century is when Italians start eating pasta regularly.
有些地区至今实际上并没有真正大规模地消费它。等等，你是说直到 20 世纪，意大利面在意大利都不是什么大不了的东西？没错。比如说在巴西利卡塔（Basilicata），也就是我家族所在的那个地区，如果当地的公爵或贵族提供了面粉，人们可能还会在节日里吃上一顿意大利面。他们可能会知道世界上有意大利面这种东西，
Some regions still don't really consume it in a significant way at all. Wait, you're telling me that pasta wasn't a big thing in Italy until the 1900s? That's right. People in, let's say, Basilicata, like the region where my family is from, they might have eaten pasta on a holiday if the duke or the noble in that town provided flour. There would be a knowledge that pasta existed,
但这并不是日常饮食的一部分。但这，这让我感到很惊讶。嗯-hmm。我的意思是，这让它成了一件相对较新的事情。意大利面作为意大利国家认同的一部分，其实是 20 世纪的事情。凯蒂解释说，意大利各个独立的地区直到 19 世纪末才被统一为一个国家。
but it wasn't a daily thing. But that's, like, that's surprising to me. Mm-hmm. I mean, that makes it a relatively new thing. Pasta as part of an Italian national identity is a 20th century thing. Katie explains that Italy's separate regions were just unified into one country in the late 1800s.
20 世纪初，法西斯主义者上台，他们需要设法养活不断增长的人口。他们还希望将人民团结在同一个民族认同之下。他们认为解决这两个问题的答案就是意大利面，因为面食便宜且易于制作，而且在国家的某些地区它已经是主食了。于是，法西斯政府在以前没有面食工厂的地区建造了工厂，
In the early 1900s, the fascists come to power and they need to figure out how to feed a growing population. They also want to unite the people under one nationalist identity. They decide the solution to both problems is pasta, because it's cheap and easy to make, and it's already a staple in some parts of the country. So the fascist government builds pasta factories in regions where there were none before,
包括在罗马。这里有非常棒的法西斯宣传资料档案，比如你能想象到的一切他们试图作为新意大利认同元素来推广的东西，而意大利面在其中确实占据了重要位置。但这只是，这让我感到很惊讶，因为意大利人对意大利面保护得那么严。完全是这样，他们会告诉你这是正宗的，
including in Rome. There's a really great archive of, like, fascist propaganda, like, everything you can imagine that they're trying to promote as elements of a new Italian identity and pasta really figures into that. But it's just, it's just surprising to me because Italians are so protective of pasta. Completely, and they'll tell you it's authentic
我们已经这样做了很长时间，但这往往并不完全准确。这也是我一直在试图弄清楚我应该如何处理这本食谱的一个问题——我的意面形状遭到了意大利人的很多质疑，这没关系，可以理解。话虽如此，事实上它作为意大利的国家级菜肴基本上也就只有 100 年的历史，
and we've been making this for a long time, but it's often not totally accurate. It's something that I'm trying to sort of figure out how I should go about with this cookbook is my pasta shape has faced a lot of skepticism from Italians, which is fine, understandable. That being said, like, the fact that it only has been basically the national dish of Italy for 100 years
这让我觉得它其实是一个比初看之下更能接纳新想法的领域。是的，根据意大利人来自哪里，他们可能会排斥它。但如果它吃起来很美味，而且你不断强迫他们去吃，他们就能接受了。
makes me feel like it's a space that is actually more open to new ideas than maybe might seem at first glance. Yeah, and Italians might reject it depending on where they're from. But if it tastes delicious and you keep forcing them to eat it, they can get on board.
对。对。对。对。对。对。那天晚上，我和凯蒂在 Cesare Al Casaletto 餐厅碰面吃晚饭。我曾请她带我看看罗马意面新想法的例子。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That evening, Katie and I meet up for dinner at Cesare Al Casaletto. I had asked her to show me examples of new ideas in pasta and rome.
创新都在哪里发生呢？于是她带我去尝试主厨莱昂纳多·皮亚（Leonardo Pia）的炸面疙瘩（gnocchi）配奶酪黑胡椒酱（cacio e pepe）。电视经纪人们，它吃起来就像薯条球（tater tots）。油炸的，我的意思是，我可以天天吃油炸面疙瘩，直到永远。此外，我还会吃，我会把这些蘸上牧场沙拉酱。没错！这道炸面疙瘩配奶酪黑胡椒酱，直到永远。此外，我会吃，我会把这些蘸上牧场沙拉酱。没错。这道炸面疙瘩配奶酪黑胡椒酱简直绝了。
Where's the innovation happening? So she takes me to try Chef Leonardo Pia's deep fried gnocchi with cacio e pepe sauce. TV agents, it tastes like tater tots. Deep fried, I mean I could eat deep fried gnocchi every day forever. Also, I would eat, I would dip these in ranch. Yes! This deep fried gnocchi with c forever. Also, I would eat, I would dip these in ranch. Yes. This deep fried gnocchi with cacio e pepe sauce is incredible.
当莱昂纳多走到我们桌旁聊天时，他告诉我这道菜的诞生是因为他厨房里一直备着这些食材。有一天，他决定把它们组合在一起。正如他所说，很多烹饪演变就是这样发生的。把它们组合在一起。正如他所说，很多烹饪演变就是这样发生的。饱餐一顿后，是时候结束这一天了。我们今天收获颇丰，凯蒂。我们做了很多。你是说卡路里摄入量吧？第二天，我和凯蒂碰头吃了另一顿晚餐，这次去了一家名叫阿曼多·阿尔·万神殿（Armando al Pantheon）的小餐馆。
And when Leonardo comes over to our table to chat, he tells me the dish came about because he has these ingredients in the kitchen all the time. One day, he decided to combine them. As he says, this is how a lot of culinary evolution happens. to combine them. As he says, this is how a lot of culinary evolution happens. After the feast, it's time to call it a night. We accomplished a lot today, Katie. We did a lot. You're talking calorically, right? The next day, Katie and I meet up for another dinner, this time at a trattoria called Armando
阿曼多在万神殿。菲利平（Philipne），你还需要什么……这里的格里吉亚意面（Grigia）相当传奇。Grigia。Grigia。Grigia。那就是没有鸡蛋的卡宴培根蛋面。所以，虽然这确实描述了它，但这意味着卡宴培根蛋面出现得更早。但事实上，Grigia 才是牧羊人意面的鼻祖，它由黑胡椒、佩科里诺罗马羊奶酪（Pecorino）和猪颊肉（guanciale）制成。他们店里还加入了白葡萄酒。
al Panteone. Armando at the Pantheon. Anything else that you, Philipine, need to... The Grigia here is pretty legendary. Grigia. Grigia. Grigia. That's Carbonara without eggs. So, while that does describe it, it implies that Carbonara was first. But in fact, Grigia is the OG shepherd's pasta that's made with pepper, pecorino, guanciale. They make theirs with white wine as well.
然后将其与意大利面拌在一起。这道菜已经流传了……猪颊肉是腌制的猪脸肉，类似于培根，但没有那么烟熏，猪肉味更浓。服务员把格里吉亚意面端到了我们的桌上。祝您用餐愉快。那些就像是厚厚的猪颊肉块。是的。
And that's tossed with pasta. And that was run for... Guanciale is cured pork jowl, similar to bacon, but not so smoky, more porky. The server brings the gritschia over to our table. Bon appetito. Those are like slabs of guanciale. Yeah.
这简直太棒了。这是我的最爱之一。不仅意面的牙齿嵌入感完美，猪颊肉肉香十足且边缘酥脆，佩科里诺羊奶酪像一层新鲜降落的雪一样堆在上面，而且他们撒在顶部的黑胡椒是碾碎的整粒胡椒，既有泥土的芬芳又香气扑鼻。回想起来，这可能是我在意大利吃过的最好吃的一道面食。
This is outstanding. One of my faves. Not only is the pasta perfectly tooth-sinkable, and the guanciale perfectly meaty with crispy edges, and the pecorino mounded on top like a perfectly fresh snowfall, but the black pepper they sprinkle on top is cracked whole peppercorns, earthy and fragrant. Looking back, it's probably the single best pasta dish I ate in Italy.
正如凯蒂所说，Grigia 是一种牧羊人意面。它最早出现在意大利的乡村。但在 20 世纪中叶，大量人口从乡村向城市迁移。正是在那里，据传说，Grigia 孕育出了它两个最著名的“孩子”。这道菜在加入番茄酱变成阿特里西亚娜面（amatriciana）之前已经流传了很长一段时间，最后在 50 年代末和 60 年代年初加入鸡蛋变成了卡宴培根蛋面。等等，卡宴培根蛋面直到 20 世纪 50 年代才出现？凯蒂接连抛出了重磅炸弹。
As Katie said, Grigio was a shepherd's pasta. It first appeared in the Italian countryside. But in the mid-1900s, there was a huge migration from the country into cities. That's where, legend has it, Grigio gave birth to its two most famous babies. And that was around for a really long time before it's enriched with tomato sauce to make a matriciana, and then ultimately enriched with egg in the late 50s and early 60s to make carbonara. Wait, carbonara only dates back to the 1950s? Katie's dropping bombshells left and right.
我一直以为罗马皇帝吃过卡宴培根蛋面。结果证明我的父母年纪都比它大。而且这可能还不是其中最让人震惊的事情。在经历了三顿史诗般的饕餮大餐后，我向凯蒂告别，准备离开罗马向南进发。但在我向你讲述更多关于我的旅行之前，我想更深入地探讨一下卡宴培根蛋面的历史，因为它对我们理解意大利菜的演变有着极大的启发意义。这就是卢卡·切萨里（Luca Cesari）。他是一位住在博洛尼亚的美食作家兼历史学家。去年他出版了一本书，名为《意大利面的发现》（The Discovery of Pasta），其中有一整章都在讲卡宴培根蛋面的历史。
I always assumed the Roman emperors ate carbonara. Turns out my parents are older. And that may not even be the most shocking thing about it. After three epic meals, I say goodbye to Katie and prepare to leave Rome and head south. But before I tell you more about my trip, I want to dive deeper into the history of Carbonara, because it has a lot to tell us about the evolution of Italian food. This is Luca Cesari. He's a food writer and historian based in Bologna. Last year he published a book called The Discovery of Pasta, which has a whole chapter on the history of Carbonara.
我在一位名叫莉莉娅·皮诺-布兰（Lilia Pino-Bluin）的口译员的帮助下采访了卢卡。我们都以为卡宴培根蛋面自中世纪以来就一直存在，历经岁月从未改变。今天，任何一个意大利人都会告诉你，卡宴培根蛋面是用猪颊肉、生打散的鸡蛋、佩科里诺罗马羊奶酪和黑胡椒制成的酱汁包裹着意面的菜肴。但卢卡表示，意大利人只是在过去 20 年里才对这个食谱达成共识。事实上，在卡宴培根蛋面的历史长河中，人们曾往其中添加过无数其他食材。
I talked to Luca with the help of an interpreter named Lilia Pino-Bluin. We all thought that Carbonara had existed forever and ever since the Middle Ages. Today, any Italian will tell you that carbonara is a pasta coated in a sauce made from guanciale, raw beaten eggs, Pecorino Romano cheese, and black pepper. But Luca says Italians only coalesced around this recipe in the last 20 years. In fact, over the course of carbonara's history, tons of other ingredients have been used in carbonara.
卢卡向我讲述了 1954 年刊登在《Harper's Bazaar》（时尚芭莎）杂志上的一份食谱。《Harper's Bazaar》刊登了唯一一份带有 Vongole Tartato 的食谱。蛤蜊？所以它是用蛤蜊做的。切碎的蛤蜊，切碎的蛤蜊。蛤蜊，切碎的蛤蜊、帕玛森奶酪和鸡蛋。
Luca tells me about one recipe printed in Harper's Bazaar in 1954. Harper's Bazaar makes the only recipe with the Vongole Tartato. Clams? So it's made with clams. Chopped clams, chopped clams. Clams, chopped clams, parmesan and eggs.
卢卡，如果你今天走进意大利的一家餐厅或者随便哪位 Nona（奶奶）的家里，说：“请给我来一份加了碎蛤蜊的传统卡宴培根蛋面”，会发生什么？他们真的会直接把你送到疯人院去。他们会把你绑起来，然后把你抬进疯人院。几十年来，奶油是卡宴培根蛋面的另一种常见配料，尽管卢卡说今天大多数意大利人一想到这个就会气得直拍胸口。不过，他们可能会觉得“卡宴培根蛋面如此年轻”这个宏观概念才是最离谱的。
Luca, what would happen if you went into a restaurant or any Nona's house in Italy today and said, I would like traditional carbonara with chopped clams, please? They would literally take you straight to a madhouse. They would put you in restraints and carry you out to a madhouse. For decades, cream was another common addition to carbonara, even though Luca says most Italians today would clutch their cannolis at the thought. Still, they might find the larger idea that carbonara is so relatively new to be most scandalous.
卢卡花了数年时间翻阅报纸档案、食谱以及其他流行文化遗物来证实这一点。在 1949 年之前，根本没有被称为卡宴培根蛋面的面食的踪迹。卢卡说，在此之前有一些可能是卡宴培根蛋面前身的菜肴，比如我前面提到的 Grigia。根据他的研究，他认为卡宴培根蛋面
Luca has spent years pouring through newspaper archives, cookbooks, and other pop culture artifacts to confirm this. Before 1949, there's no trace of a pasta dish known as carbonara. Luca says there were earlier dishes that might have been forerunners to carbonara, like grecia, which I mentioned earlier. Based on his research, he believes carbonara
很可能是在二战结束时美国士兵驻扎在罗马时诞生的。美军配给的罐装培根和鸡蛋进入了意大利人的厨房。人们可能萌生了将它们与意大利面以及一些奶酪混合在一起的想法。然后这道菜在军队和美国军官中变得非常非常受欢迎，因为它融合了最传统的意大利食物——意大利面，
likely came about when American soldiers were in Rome at the end of World War II. American rations of canned bacon and eggs made their way into Italian kitchens. And people might have had the idea of mixing it in with pasta and probably some cheese. And then this dish became very, very popular among the troops and the American officers because it was a mix of the most traditional Italian food that is spaghetti or pasta, and
以及美式早餐的风味。这在大西洋的两岸之间架起了一座桥梁。那么，说卡宴培根蛋面是一种烹饪融合（culinary fusion）的形式，这公平吗？是的。没错，它是终极的烹饪杂交典范。所以卡宴培根蛋面很可能只有在二战期间身处意大利的美国人的参与下才能诞生。这就是为什么卢卡称它为“在意大利诞生的美国菜”。换句话说，我远不是第一个为意大利面的演变做出贡献的美国人。
then the flavors of an Anglo-American breakfast. And that creates a bridge between the two sides of the Atlantic. So is it fair to say that carbonara is a form of culinary fusion? Yeah. Yes, it is the ultimate culinary hybrid par excellence. So Carbonara could probably only have come into existence with contributions from Americans who were in Italy during World War II. That's why Luca calls it an American dish born in Italy. In other words, I'm far from the first American to contribute to pasta's evolution.
但即使在卡宴培根蛋面刚被创造出来的时候，人们对它的配料也没有达成广泛共识。卢卡说，旧食谱经常把奶酪列为帕玛森（Parmigiano）而不是佩科里诺（Pecorino），肉类则列为培根或 pancetta（本质上是意大利培根），而不是猪颊肉。意大利印刷的第一份食谱里用的是 pancetta 和格鲁耶尔奶酪（gruyere），一种甚至都不是意大利产的奶酪。其他食谱里有蘑菇或大蒜，还有那份臭名昭著的加蛤蜊的食谱。
But even when Carbonara was created, there was not widespread agreement on what the ingredients were. Luca says old cookbooks often list the cheese as Parmigiano instead of Pecorino, and the meat as bacon or pancetta, which is basically Italian bacon, instead of guanciale. The very first recipe printed in Italy had pancetta and gruyere, a cheese that's not even Italian. Other recipes had mushrooms or garlic, and there was that infamous one with the clams.
卢卡告诉我，当他与意大利人分享他的研究成果时，有些人会表示反对。他们坚信自己祖母的祖母做卡宴培根蛋面的方法和今天人们的做法一模一样。但也有一些人对新的视角持开放态度。围绕美食的故事讲述正在发生改变。有些人确实开始说，嗯，也许我们直到现在互相讲述的那些事情并没有那么真实。
Luca tells me when he shares his research with Italians, some of them object. They insist their grandmother's grandmother made carbonara the exact same way people make it today. But others are open to a new perspective. The storytelling around cuisine is changing. Some people do start to say, well, maybe what we've told each other up until now is not all that realistic.
也许是时候让我们听听那些做研究的人和拥有文献的人的话了，也许我们美食的历史并不像我们一直以来想象的那样呈线性发展。所以，卢卡，我正在写一本食谱。我正试图向人们展示，你可以而且应该在意面上放更多种类的食材。一方面，我对意大利美食和文化有着极大的尊重。我热爱意大利美食和文化。好吧。我也想以我自己的方式去玩味它。
Maybe the time has come for us to listen to those who do research and those who have documents, and maybe the history of our gastronomy is not as linear as we've always thought it was. So Luca, I am writing a cookbook. I am trying to show people that there are a lot more ingredients that you can and should put on pasta. On one hand, I have a great respect for Italian food and culture. I love Italian food and culture. Okay. I also want to play with it in my own way.
是的。所以当我在写这本食谱时，当我试图这样做时，你有什么建议给我？哦。通过 Zoom 视频，卢卡摇了摇头，向我摇了摇手指，仿佛在说：我没有什么建议。他只有一个鼓励的词，而且他甚至不需要翻译。
Yeah. So as I work on this cookbook, as I attempt to do that, what advice do you have for me? Oh. Over Zoom, Lucas shakes his head and wags a finger at me, as if to say, I don't have advice. He just has one word of encouragement, and he doesn't need a translator.
去吧。哈哈哈哈。去吧。哈哈哈哈。[♪ 音乐播放。在与卢卡交谈后，我感到更有底气去在面食创作中加入我自己的特色，并认为也许意大利人应该为他们美食的持续演变给予更多肯定，我觉得这令人兴奋。接下来，我们将继续我的意大利之旅，我将一路旅行到这个国家靴子鞋跟的最南端，去寻找我在美国餐馆里从未见过的主食。
Go. Ha ha ha. Go. Ha ha ha. [♪ music playing. After talking with Luca, I'm feeling emboldened to put my own spin on pasta dishes and thinking that maybe Italians should give their cuisine more credit for its continued evolution, which I find exciting. Coming up, we pick up my Italy trip when I journey all the way to the southern tip of
敬请期待。现在，听听我们赞助商带来的精彩广告。欢迎回到 The Sporkful。我是丹·帕什曼。我有一个好消息要宣布。我要带着《Sporkful》去巡回演出了！当我的食谱出版时，我会举办一系列的现场播客录制和新书签售活动。我将与一些了不起的人物进行对话，足迹遍布纽约、长岛、芝加哥、双子城、亚特兰大、迈阿密、华盛顿特区、费城、波士顿、洛杉矶、旧金山、西雅图，而且还会有更多城市加入。有关所有详情以及我的特邀嘉宾完整名单，请访问 sporkful.com
the heel of the country's boot to find three pasta dishes I've never seen in an American restaurant. Stick around. And now a delicious word from our sponsors. Welcome back to The Sporkful. I'm Dan Pashman. I got some exciting news. I am taking the Sporkful on tour. When my cookbook comes out, I'm doing a series of live podcast tapings and book signings. I'll be in conversation with some incredible folks hitting New York, Long Island, Chicago, the Twin Cities, Atlanta, Miami, DC, Philly, Boston, LA, San Francisco, Seattle, and still more to come. For all the details and the full list of my special guests, go to sporkful.com.com
/tour。好了，言归正传，回到意大利。在罗马度过的几天里，我学到了许多至关重要的信息，也吃了很多意面。但现在是时候继续前程了。我登上了开往普利亚（Puglia）地区的火车。随着我向南旅行，意大利的山脉和丘陵逐渐平缓。空气变得尘土飞扬。这里出现了棕榈树和仙人掌。我在车程中花了很多时间试图弄清楚意大利到底有没有真正的沙漠，但这证明是个不小的挑战，因为谷歌拒绝相信我不是在搜索意大利甜点（Italian desserts）。六个多小时后，我抵达了意大利东南角的莱切（Lecce）市。即使你从未去过意大利，你也一定听说过罗马、佛罗伦萨、威尼斯、米兰、西西里、托斯卡纳、阿马尔菲海岸。莱切并不在这些地方附近。
slash tour. Okay, back to Italy. Over several days in Rome, I learned a lot of crucial information and ate a lot of pasta. But now it's time to move on. I board a train to the region of Puglia. As I travel south, Italy's mountains and hills flatten. The air becomes dusty. There are palm trees and cacti. I spend a lot of time on the ride trying to figure out whether Italy has actual deserts, but it proves challenging because Google refuses to believe I don't mean to be searching for Italian desserts. After more than six hours I arrive in the city of Lecce in the southeastern corner of Italy. Even if you've never been to Italy, you've heard of Rome, Florence, Venice, Milan, Sicily, Tuscany, the Amalfi coast. Lecce is not near any of those places.
这里的水源不足以养活家畜，这意味着这里没有乳制品，几乎也没有肉类。所以这里的食物与意大利其他地方大相径庭，也与大多数美国人所熟知的意大利经典菜肴截然不同，这使得它完美契合我的食谱需求。我见到了西尔维斯特罗·西尔维斯特里（Silvestro Silvestori），他在莱切经营着一家名为“The Awaiting Table”的烹饪学校。Buongiorno。
There's not enough water to sustain livestock, which means there's no dairy and almost no meat. So the food here is very different from the rest of Italy and from the Italian classics most Americans know, which makes it perfect for my cookbook. I meet Silvestro Silvestori, who runs a cooking school in Lecce called The Awaiting Table. Buongiorno.
哦，哇，这房间太酷了。西尔维斯特罗出生于意大利，在美国长大，成年后又搬回了意大利。他成为了被称为 cucina povera（意为“穷人菜”、“农民菜”）流派的学生和老师。从历史上看，穷人被迫吃大量的绿叶蔬菜，被迫吃大量的豆类。萨兰托（Salento）的“猪”实际上可能就是鹰嘴豆或扁豆。许许多多、各式各样的豆类。所以，当其他意大利人可能在吃火腿（prosciutto）和马苏里拉奶酪时，萨兰托的人们传统上一直都在吃那些在干旱气候下生长良好的豆类。
Oh wow, this is such a cool room. Silvestro was born in Italy, grew up in America, then moved back to Italy as an adult. He became a student and teacher of what's called cucina povera, meaning the cuisine of poverty, peasant food. Poor people historically were forced to eat a lot of greens, forced to eat a lot of legumes. The pig of the Salento was actually probably the chickpea or the lentil. Lots and lots and lots of legumes. So where other Italians might be eating prosciutto and mozzarella, people in the Salento have traditionally eaten legumes, which grow well in dry climates.
这些豆类构成了我在此次研究中偶然发现的两道菜的基础，这也是我来到西尔维斯特罗的烹饪学校学习的目的。其中一道菜是油炸面豆汤（ciceri e tria），它将油炸意面和水煮意面结合在鹰嘴豆汤中。西尔维斯特罗为我做了这道菜，它超级简单，但也令人惊叹。嗯，这太好吃了。酥脆与有嚼劲的意面口感的结合简直妙不可言。下一道菜是蚕豆泥配菊苣（fave e chicoria），
These legumes form the basis of the two dishes I've come across in my research that I've journeyed to Silvestro's cooking school to learn about. One dish is chicharri tria, which combines deep-fried pasta and boiled pasta in a chickpea broth. Silvestro makes it for me, and it's super simple, but also kind of mind-blowing. Mmm, that is so good. The combination of the crispy and chewy pasta textures is transcendent. The next dish is fave chicoria,
这是一种蚕豆泥和苦味绿叶蔬菜菊苣的组合。在莱切，他们就这样直接上这道菜——做成泥状，通常配上用来蘸着吃面包。但我的食谱研发人员凯蒂·莱尔德（Katie Laird，又名“超级奶奶” Super Nona）曾在这里生活和烹饪过，
a puree of fava beans and chicory, which is a bitter green. In leche, they serve it just like that, a puree, often with bread for dipping. But my recipe developer, Katie Laird, AKA Supernona, lived and cooked here in bread for dipping. But my recipe developer, Katie Laird, aka Super Nona, lived and cooked here in Puglia and suggested something pretty revolutionary, which I run by Silvestro. So the idea with fave ciccoria, this may be controversial, but we're thinking about
她提出了一个相当革命性的想法，我把它拿去跟西尔维斯特罗探讨。所以关于蚕豆泥配菊苣这道菜，这可能有点争议，但我们在考虑把它改编成一道意面。你觉得怎么样？改个名字。或者说是“受其启发”之类的那种。对。拿这样一道菜开玩笑，然后说“我帮你把它改良了”。我的意思是，杰米·奥利弗（Jamie Oliver）经常遇到这种问题。他来到意大利，然后他，你知道的……
adapting it into a pasta dish. What do you think of that? Change of name. Or inspired by or that sort of thing. Right. Playing with something like this is a dish and saying I've improved this for you. I mean, Jamie Oliver has this problem all the time. He comes to Italy and he, you know,
但他往里面加了肉丸，而他期望的……他就像一只以为你一定会喜欢它咬坏了你的拖鞋的狗狗一样，对吧？当一道菜本身已经很完美时，对其进行重新诠释就没有什么价值了。我们如何给食谱命名，其实是我在这个项目中思考了很久的事情。你知道的，我正在做一个泡菜卡宴培根蛋面的食谱。
but I put meatballs in it and he expect, he's like a dog who expects that you love the fact that he chewed your slippers, right? There's no value of it being reinterpreted when it's already perfect. How we name the recipes is something I've actually thought a lot about during this project. You know, I'm doing a recipe for kimchi carbonara
但我往里面放了肉丸，他却期望……他就像一只狗，以为你很爱他咬坏了你的拖鞋一样，对吧？当它已经完美时，重新诠释就没有任何价值了。菜谱该如何命名，其实是我在这个项目中深入思考过的一个问题。你知道的，我正在做一道泡菜卡博纳拉意面
and I think calling it carbonara is fair game. It's carbonara with one ingredient added. But in the case of 5-H Icoria, I do get what Silvestro's saying. It isn't a pasta dish at all. So while Katie and I will make it into a pasta dish, we're not gonna claim that it is 5H Ikoria. We'll give it its own name
我觉得把它叫作卡波娜拉意面是完全合理的。它就是加了一种配料的卡波娜拉。但对于5-H伊科里亚，我确实明白西尔维斯特洛的意思。它根本不是一道面食。所以，虽然我和凯蒂会把它做成一道面食，但我们不会声称它是5H伊科里亚。我们会给它起个自己的名字
and say it's inspired by 5H Ikoria. So should I show you how to make this? Yeah, let's do it. Silvestro and I make the traditional version of the dish, which will give me a reference point for the pasta I'll develop with Katie. He finishes it with what a recipe writer might call a drizzle of olive oil,
并说它是受5H伊科里亚启发而做的。那么，我该向你展示怎么做这个吗？行，我们开始吧。西尔维斯特洛和我做了这道菜的传统版本，这将为我与凯蒂共同研发的意面提供一个参考点。他在最后淋上了菜谱作者可能会称之为一小股的橄榄油，
but in reality is multiple glugs of it. The olive oil is pooling in the bottom of the bowl here, and it does not feel like too much because it's not just like a little bit of lubrication, it's like an ingredient. When I put a bite of this into my mouth, I am tasting a lot of olive oil. The fava beans are rich and creamy,
但实际上是好几大勺。橄榄油此时汇聚在碗底，感觉并没有放太多，因为它不只是起一点润滑作用，它就像是一种食材。当我把一口这个放进嘴里时，我尝到了大量的橄榄油。蚕豆口感浓郁且绵密，
the chicory is crunchy and bitter, and the olive oil is peppery and herbaceous. I can't wait to taste this over pasta. My journey to one of the farthest corners of Italy has been worth it. While the two dishes I came here to research will still require a lot of recipe testing and development before they're ready to go into the book, I've confirmed that they're really special, and I can't wait to share them. From Lecce, I travel an hour north to another city in Puglia,
菊苣爽脆带苦，橄榄油则带有胡椒般的辛辣和草本的芳香。我已经迫不及待想在面食里尝尝这个了。我前往意大利最偏远角落之一的旅程非常值得。虽然我来这里研究的两道菜在准备收入书本之前，仍然需要大量的食谱测试和研发，但我已经确信它们非常特别，而且我迫不及待地想与大家分享。从莱切出发，我向北行驶了一个小时，来到了普利亚的另一个城市，
Bari. This is where I'll have my first taste of a dish called spaghetti alla sassina. Spaghetti alla sassina literally means Assassin's spaghetti. It's spaghetti cooked in spicy tomato sauce, pan-fried until the pasta turns charred and crispy crunchy. Like chicharritrilla, it's another dish that incorporates crispy fried pasta, although this is pan-fried. It's only made in the city of Bari, and I am incredibly excited about its unconventional combination of textures and flavors. I take my first taste of spaghetti al'asasina. It smells burnt and tomatoey. Minutes after getting off the train, I'm sitting at a restaurant called Giotto Panzerotto.
巴里。在这里，我们将首次品尝到一盘名为萨西纳意面（Spaghetti alla Sassina）的菜肴。萨西纳意面字面上的意思是“刺客意面”。它是用辣番茄酱烹制的意面，经过平底锅煎炸，直到面条变得焦黑、酥脆。就像奇查里特里拉一样，这也是一道融入了油炸酥脆意面的菜肴，不过这是用平底锅煎的。它只在巴里市制作，我对它那非传统的质感和风味组合感到非常兴奋。我吃下了第一口萨西纳意面。它闻起来有焦香味和浓郁的番茄味。下火车几分钟后，我就坐在了一家名为Giotto Panzerotto的餐厅里。
A friend from Bari told me this place has his favorite asasini. Now I have a hot charred tower of it in front of me. This is amazing. It's honestly so much better than I expected it to be. You got the burnt rispybits and the doughy bits. I knew I'd like the pasta, crispy crunchy on the outside and chewy inside, and the spice. I didn't anticipate the role the tomato sauce would play. It cooks down to a sticky sweet spicy paste, which adds great flavor and another contrast in texture.
一个巴里朋友告诉我，这家店有他最喜欢的萨西纳意面。现在，我面前就摆着一座滚烫焦黑的意面小塔。这太棒了。说实话，它比我预期的要好得多。你能吃到焦脆的部分和面团般的部分。我知道我会喜欢这种意面，外表酥脆，内里筋道，还有辣味。我没有预料到番茄酱会起到这样的作用。它被熬煮成了一种浓稠香甜的辣酱，增添了极佳的风味和另一种质感的对比。
The asasina at Ghiotto is fantastic, but I don't really have anything to compare it to. I need more of a frame of reference. So I continue my assasine crawl at a restaurant called Che Joe, where I discuss the dish with other diners. I think that the secret is don't boil the spaghetti. This man, Vincenzo, explains that there's a big debate in Bari about Spaghetti alla Sassina.
Ghiotto餐厅的萨西纳意面棒极了，但我真的没有东西可以拿它作比较。我需要更多的参考框架。于是我继续在一家名为Che Joe的餐厅进行我的萨西纳意面探索，在那里我和其他食客讨论了这道菜。我认为秘诀就是不要煮意面。这位名叫文森佐的男士解释说，巴里关于萨西纳意面有一场激烈的辩论。
Some people boil the pasta a bit before putting it in the pan with the sauce, just to soften it a little. Others put raw, dried pasta straight into the pan with the sauce. Vincenzo makes clear which side he's on. No, no boiled spaghetti before. Don't boil it. In the pan. What's boil it? The pan. What's the meaning of a pan? A pan.
有些人把面条稍微煮一下，然后才放进平底锅和酱汁一起炒，只是为了让它稍微变软。另一些人则把生干面条直接和酱汁一起放进平底锅里。文森佐明确表态他支持哪一方。不，之前不能煮意面。不要煮。在锅里。什么是煮？锅。锅是什么意思？锅。
Yes. So, the spaghetti, in the spaghetti all'assassina, I know normally you want pasta al dente. But for spaghetti, I feel like at Giotto, the inside of the pasta was not so al dente. It was a little more soft. Yes. Which is good because the outside is hard. Yes. It's the same.
是的。所以，在萨西纳意面中，我知道通常你希望意面是阿尔登特（有嚼劲）的。但对于这款意面，我觉得在Giotto餐厅，意面内部并不是那么有嚼劲。它更软一些。是的。这很好，因为外面是硬的。是的。这是一样的。
Yes. So here, I think the pasta was al dente. It was cooked perfecto for al dente. But for asasina, you don't want al dente, but for asasina, you don't want al dente. Yes, you need two different consistencies. Yes, consistency, right, different textures. Yes, soft and hard.
是的。所以在这里，我认为意面是有嚼劲的。它的熟度非常完美，达到了阿尔登特的状态。但对于萨西纳意面，你不需要阿尔登特，但对于萨西纳意面，你不需要阿尔登特。是的，你需要两种不同的浓稠度。是的，浓稠度，没错，不同的质感。是的，软的和硬的。
Yes. Crispy, so when you eat crispy, crunch, crunch, crunch. It's perfect. Yes. This guy's speaking my language. So I want you to eat crispy, crunch, crunch, crunch. Yes, this guy's speaking my language. Vincenzo even teaches me my new favorite Italian word, the word for crunchy, croccante. It even sounds crunchy. As I leave, Vincenzo asked me what hotel I'm staying at.
是的。酥脆，所以当你吃的时候会听到酥脆、咔嚓、咔嚓、咔嚓的声音。太完美了。是的。这家伙说的是我的语言。所以我想让你吃得酥脆、咔嚓、咔嚓、咔嚓。是的，这家伙说的是我的语言。文森佐甚至教了我我最喜欢的新的意大利语单词，意为酥脆的词是croccante。听起来就很酥脆。当我离开时，文森佐问我住在哪个酒店。
He would later drop off a copy of an Italian mystery novel called Spaghetti alla Sassina, in which a fictional inventor of the dish is murdered. It's the fifth in a series of books featuring Bari's most dogged detective, Inspector Lolita Labosco. It's in Italian, so I'm probably not gonna read it, but I love it. Before I feel ready to recreate this dish from my cookbook,
他后来送来了一本名为《萨西纳意面》的意大利悬疑小说，书中的虚构小说里，这道菜的发明者被谋杀了。这是以巴里最顽强的侦探洛莉塔·拉博斯科督察为主角的系列书籍中的第五本。它是意大利语的，所以我可能不会读它，但我很喜欢。在我准备好为我的食谱重现这道菜之前，
there's one more place I have to go. Good to see you again, my friend. Good to see you again. I meet up with Antonello Di Bari, who I first met through Pasta Circles. He runs a pasta factory in Bari. He agreed to show you again. I meet up with Antonello Di Bari, who I first met through Pasta Circles. He runs a pasta factory in Bari. He agreed to show me around. I tell Antonello about my plans to include Spaghetti alla Sassina in my cookbook.
还有一个地方我必须去。很高兴再次见到你，我的朋友。很高兴再次见到你。我见到了安东内洛·迪·巴里（Antonello Di Bari），我最初是通过“面食圈”认识他的。他在巴里经营一家面食厂。他同意再次带你参观。我见到了安东内洛·迪·巴里，我最初是通过“面食圈”认识他的。他在巴里经营一家面食厂。他同意带我四处看看。我告诉安东内洛我计划把萨西纳意面收录到我的食谱中。
A lot of people, even in Italy, don't know about it. People must know about it. Yeah, because it's tasty, it's crunchy, and you can never stop eating it. Antonello and I arrive at a restaurant called Al Sorso Preferito, the restaurant where spaghetti alla sassina was invented. You know, it's rare that you can pinpoint the time and place a pasta dish was born. As we heard from the food writer and historian Luca Cesari, most pasta history is the stuff of lore.
很多人，甚至在意大利，都不知道这道菜。人们必须知道它。是的，因为它很美味，很酥脆，而且你根本停不下来。我和安东内洛到达了一家名为Al Sorso Preferito的餐厅，这就是发明萨西纳意面的那家餐厅。你知道，你很少能精确指出一道面食诞生的时间和地点。正如我们从美食作家兼历史学家卢卡·切萨里那里听到的那样，大多数面食历史都属于传说。
But assasina is one of the few that we do have a documented story for. From what I've heard from the food writer and historian Luca Cesari, most pasta history is the stuff of lore. But Assasina is one of the few that we do have a documented story for. Al Sorso Preferito has white tablecloths, tile floors, shiny wood finishes, and wine bottles on shelves along the walls. We're going to meet a chef who is one of the inventors of spaghetti all'Assasina. But first we sit down with another important figure in the dishes story Massimo de la herba Lot of titles among them. I am president of the academia of the last Asina President of the Academy of the Asasina. You said you have many titles Massimo. What are your other titles besides? I am a owner of the gunshot residues. Gunshot residues?
但萨西纳意面是少数有据可查的故事的菜肴之一。从我从美食作家兼历史学家卢卡·切萨里那里听到的来看，大多数面食历史都属于传说。但萨西纳意面是少数有据可查的故事的菜肴之一。Al Sorso Preferito餐厅铺着白色的桌布，瓷砖地面，光亮的木质装饰，墙边的架子上摆满了酒瓶。我们要去见一位发明了萨西纳意面的厨师。但首先，我们坐下来与这道菜故事中的另一位重要人物马西莫·德·拉·埃尔巴交谈，他有很多头衔。我是最后一道萨西纳意面学院的主席。萨西纳意面学院的主席。你说你有很多头衔，马西莫。除了这个，你还有什么头衔？我是枪击残留物的拥有者。枪击残留物？
Oh, like forensics? Yes. So you have always had a fascination with assassins and killers. Yes. Massimo's Academy of the Assassasina started as a joke. He and some friends set out to taste the dish at the restaurants around Bari that served it, with a rigorous scoring system that rated each version
哦，就像法医科学那样？是的。所以你一直对刺客和杀手着迷。是的。马西莫的萨西纳意面学院最初是一个玩笑。他和一些朋友出发去品尝巴里周边供应这道菜的餐馆里的版本，并采用了一套严格的评分系统来对每个版本进行评分，
on crunch, spice, and char. They published their results in a Facebook group which quickly grew to hundreds of members, each of whom had a different opinion about who in Bari makes the best Assasina, how crunchy and spicy it should be, and perhaps most contentious of all, whether the spaghetti should be raw or partially boiled before it's fried in the pan with the sauce. Along with the influence of social media,
评分标准包括酥脆度、辣度和焦香度。他们把结果发表在一个Facebook群组里，群组迅速发展到数百名成员，每个人对巴里谁做的萨西纳意面最好、应该有多酥脆多辣都有不同的看法，而也许最具争议的是，意面在和酱汁一起下锅煎之前，应该是生的还是稍微煮过。随着社交媒体的影响，
Massimo's academy led to something unexpected. Now, there is not a restaurant in Bari that don't make the assasina. If you think that only nine years ago, this was a dish made by only three restaurants. And back then, Massimo says nobody in Bari made the dish at home. Now he's something of a local celebrity.
马西莫的学院带来了一些意想不到的事情。现在，巴里没有一家餐馆不做萨西纳意面。如果你想想看，仅仅在九年以前，这还是一道只有三家餐厅制作的菜。而在那个时候，马西莫说巴里没有人会在家里做这道菜。现在他算是个当地的名人了。
It's strange that when somebody that I don't know meet me, ah, you are the president of the Academia. I was all a big number of other things before, but now I am known only for this. With help from Massimo, I've arranged to go into the kitchen to watch them make the dish, and to meet chef and owner Pietro Lannigro. This is the inventor?
奇怪的是，当一个我不认识的人遇到我时，会说：“啊，你是学院的主席。”我以前做过很多其他大不了的事情，但现在我只因为这个而出名。在马西莫的帮助下，我安排进入厨房观看他们制作这道菜，并见到了厨师兼老板皮埃特罗·兰尼格罗。这就是发明者？
The inventor. It's a pleasure to meet you. Pietro. He's 80 years old now, short and bald but full of energy. He's the only one still at the restaurant who was here when the dish was first invented around 1960. Chef Pietro explains that the chefs were making spaghetti with tomatoes and chili peppers, a classic dish, but they accidentally burned it.
发明者。很高兴见到你，皮埃特罗。他现在80岁了，个子不高，有些秃顶，但充满了活力。他是餐厅里唯一一个从1960年前后这道菜刚发明时就在这里的人。皮埃特罗主厨解释说，厨师们当时在做西红柿加辣椒的意面，这是一道经典菜肴，但他们不小心把它烧焦了。
They were about to throw it out, and they decided instead to eat it. Massimo translates. This crunchy was interesting. Was good. It was good. Right. It's burning, and on the different level of burning,
他们本来打算把它扔掉，但后来决定干脆吃掉它。马西莫翻译道。这种焦脆感很有趣。很好。很好。没错。这是烧焦的，在不同的烧焦程度上，
This burning on the different level of burning finally become the assassina. So when the chefs there realized they had stumbled onto something, they experimented and refined the technique. Customers started asking for it more spicy, more crunchy. Chef Pietro tells me when he eventually bought the restaurant in 1974, he kept riffing on the dish.
这种在不同烧焦程度上的焦糊最终变成了萨西纳意面。所以当那里的厨师意识到他们无意中发现了某种特别的东西时，他们进行了试验并改进了技术。顾客开始要求更辣、更酥脆的口感。皮埃特罗主厨告诉我，当他最终于1974年买下这家餐厅时，他继续对这道菜进行即兴创作。
He added the technique of rotating the pasta in the pan to char more of it, which also further reduces the sauce into that sticky tomato paste. Eventually, he settled on the spaghetti a la sasina he serves today. One of his cooks begins making it as he explains the process. Massimo looks on, and my friend Antonello takes over translating. Well, that garlic's really frying up. Once the garlic is ready. When the garlic is fried? It's really frying up. Once the garlic is ready. When the garlic is fried? It's fried, they start to add tomato sauce.
他加入了在锅中旋转面条的技术，以便让更多的面条烧焦，这也进一步将酱汁浓缩成那种黏稠的番茄酱。最终，他确定了今天供应的萨西纳意面。当他解释制作过程时，他的一名厨师开始制作这道菜。马西莫在一旁看着，我的朋友安东内洛接替了翻译工作。嗯，大蒜真的炸香了。大蒜准备好之后。大蒜炸好时？真的炸香了。大蒜准备好之后。大蒜炸好时？炸好了，他们开始加番茄酱。
Right. Now, contrary to what they do at the restaurants I visited yesterday, Chef Pietro does boil his spaghetti briefly before he fries it in the pan. But Massimo, president of the Academy, is in the no-boil camp. So he starts debating the question with Chef Pietro and the other cooks in the kitchen. What's happening? They are just discussing on how to cook it, because as I told you before, there are many different ways to do it.
没错。现在，与我昨天参观的餐馆的做法相反，皮埃特罗主厨在下锅煎之前确实先把意面稍微煮了一下。但学院主席马西莫是坚决反对煮面派。于是他开始与厨房里的皮埃特罗主厨和其他厨师就这个问题展开争论。怎么了？他们只是在讨论如何烹饪它，因为正如我之前对你所说的那样，有很多不同的做法。
So as I understand, Massimo is explaining that he does not... Cook it before. Right, right. Boil spaghetti. He puts it in the pan uncooked. Here they cook it a little bit. What do the guys who invented Assasina think about Massimo's technique?
所以据我理解，马西莫在解释说他不……烹饪前不煮。没错，没错。煮意面。他把生面条直接放进锅里。这里他们稍微煮了一下。发明萨西纳意面的那些人对马西莫的技术有什么看法？
It just said that it's a way to do it, but it's not the best way to do it. So they have discussion about that. It's so funny. The discussion grows more heated. The older man, the chef, he's explaining that, doing as Massimo usually do, the result is going to be not the same because the risk is that spaghetti can burn too much. But I didn't add during cooking, the result is gonna be different at the end.
他只是说这是一种做法，但不是最好的做法。所以他们对此进行了讨论。太搞笑了。讨论变得更加激烈。年长的男厨师在解释说，如果像马西莫通常那样做，结果将不会是一样的，因为风险在于意面可能会烧焦得太厉害。但我烹饪时没有加水，最后的结局会有所不同。
And Massimo just said, okay, you're right, but next time I come here, I'm gonna cook it for you. Just to show you which is the best. I guess in Italian pasta culture, even the guy who invented a dish can be accused of doing it wrong. At this point, the pasta's been in the pan with the sauce for 15 or 20 minutes. Right now it's starting to burn on the bottom.
而马西莫只是说，好吧，你是对的，但下次我来这里时，我要亲自为你做。只是为了向你展示哪个才是最好的。我想在意大利的面食文化中，即使是发明了一道菜的人，也会被指责做法不对。此时，意面已经在锅里和酱汁一起煮了15或20分钟。现在它开始在底部烧焦了。
Now he's really using the spatula to scrape the bottom of the pan. The spaghetti is starting to stick to the pan, which is good, right? It's starting to turn, we're starting to get some black bits. Is that finito? Yeah, ready. Oh my gosh. The cooking may be finished, but the argument isn't. It's just explaining how that you don't have to push so strongly with the spatula.
现在他真的在用铲子刮锅底了。意面开始粘锅了，这很好，对吧？它开始翻转了，我们开始看到一些黑色的碎块。这是完成了？是的，完成了。哦，天哪。烹饪可能完成了，但争论还没有。他只是在解释说你不必用铲子用力推。
Yeah, because otherwise you are going to take off even this part. You get too much of the burnt part. Yeah, that is bitter and it's not good to eat. And they are still fighting on this. Right. They're fighting over whether or not to cook the pasta in advance... ...or they're fighting over whether or not to scrape the bottom of the pan. They're just fighting for everything. Time to eat? Time to eat?
是的，因为否则你会连这一部分也铲掉。你会得到太多烧焦的部分。是的，那是苦的，不好吃。他们还在为此争吵。没错。他们是在争论是否要提前煮意面…………还是在争论是否应该刮锅底。他们什么都要争。开吃了吗？开吃了吗？
Time to eat. Alright, we're coming back out to the dining room where our plates of Assasina are waiting. The real test. We all take bites and chew thoughtfully for a minute, before Antonello delivers his verdict. It's good, but it's not my favorite one. This way to make it, maybe the original way, okay, I will not discuss. But if you are friendly with the Italian way to eat pasta. These are overcooked. The pieces that are not burned are overcooked in your opinion.
开吃吧。好了，我们回到餐厅的用餐区，我们的萨西纳意面盘子正在那里等着。真正的考验。我们都吃了一口，若有所思地咀嚼了一分钟，然后安东内洛给出了他的评判。很好，但这不是我最喜欢的。这种做法，也许是最初的做法，好吧，我不予讨论。但如果你熟悉意大利人吃意面的方式。这些煮过头了。在您看来，没有烧焦的部分是煮过头了。
They're too soft. Antonello, you agree? Yeah, I 100% agree. Few people have obtained results from academia over seven, very few. This is five. You would rate this five out of 10. Yes.
它们太软了。安东内洛，你同意吗？是的，我百分之百同意。很少有人能从学院那里得到超过七分的评价，极少数。这是五分。你会给它打10分里的5分。是的。
Yeah. Come on. I have to say, I feel the same as Massimo in Antonello. As compared with the asasina at Ghiotto, that first place I went to, this one just seems to have a little less of everything. Less spice, less crunch, less char, less sticky sweet tomato paste, and less of the nutty pasta flavor
是的。拜托。我必须说，我的感受和马西莫以及安东内洛一样。与我去的第一个地方Ghiotto的萨西纳意面相比，这个版本的各方面似乎都少了一点。辣味少一点，酥脆度少一点，焦香味少一点，黏稠香甜的番茄酱少一点，坚果般的意面风味也少一点
the pan frying it creates. Less of everything I love about it. I decide that when I work on my own recipe for my cookbook, I'll use the asasina from Ghiotto as my north star. That night I would return to eat it there a second time, to sear it into my sense memory. Back at the table with Massimo and Antonello, our conversation turns to the future of spaghetti all'assassina. As the assassina becomes more popular
平底锅煎炸所带来的风味。所有我喜欢的特色都少了一点。我决定，当我在为自己的食谱研发制作时，我将以Ghiotto的萨西纳意面作为我的北极星。那天晚上，我决定第二次回去那里吃，把它深深烙印在我的感官记忆中。回到马西莫和安东内洛所在的桌子旁，我们的谈话转向了萨西纳意面的未来。随着萨西纳意面变得越来越受欢迎，
and more known around Italy and around the world, it's natural that also it's going to change. Maybe. Evolution. New people will bring new ideas. How do you feel about that? This is normal in cooking. It's normal in all the human activities. There is nothing that remains equal over the time.
并在意大利乃至全世界越来越知名，它发生改变也是自然而然的事。也许吧。演变。新的人会带来新的想法。你对此有何感想？这在烹饪中是很正常的。在所有人类活动中这都很正常。没有什么东西是随着时间一成不变的。
Nothing stays the same? No, nothing is the same. No, nothing is the same. But you have to remember which are the origins. They must survive together. You have not to forget the origin because if you forgot the origin, you have not a point of reference. I agree, and I'm confident the people of Bari will preserve that point of reference for spaghetti alla sasina. At the same time, the inevitable evolution is already happening. In just the last few years, restaurants in the city have created new versions of the
没有什么保持不变吗？不，没有什么是一样的。不，没有什么是一样的。但你必须记住起源是什么。它们必须共存。你不能忘记起源，因为如果你忘记了起源，你就没有了参考点。我同意，而且我相信巴里的人民会为萨西纳意面保留这个参考点。与此同时，不可避免的演变已经在发生了。就在过去的几年里，这座城市的餐馆创造了这道菜的
dish, one with broccoli rabe instead of tomato sauce, another topped with a dollop of stracciatella cheese, the creamy spreadable insides of a ball of burrata. So spaghetti alla sasina is a perfect example of how, even in Italian cuisine, people continue to come up with new ideas, just as people in kitchens have always done. I come away from my time in Italy with a very different perspective on pasta culture and my place in it. I started out thinking of my book as an attempt to shake up a cuisine that might have been too stuck
新版本，其中一道用的是长茎西兰花代替番茄酱，另一道上面则盖着一勺丝滑乳酪（stracciatella），也就是布拉塔奶酪内部奶油状、可涂抹的部分。所以萨西纳意面完美地证明了，即使在意大利美食中，人们也一直在不断涌现出新的想法，就像厨房里的前辈们一直以来所做的那样。我在意大利的这段经历让我对面食文化以及我在其中的位置有了截然不同的视角。我一开始认为我的这本书是对一种可能过于墨守成规的美食的震撼尝试。
in its ways. Now I see my book as a contribution to the ongoing and never-ending evolution of pasta. ["The Last Post-Sale"] Coming up next week in episode three of Anything's Possible, I return home full of inspiration. I just think this is a good idea. This is gonna be really delicious, and I can't wait to try it. free of anything's possible, I return home full of inspiration. I just think this is a good idea.
现在我把我的书看作是对面食不断发展且永无止境的演变的一种贡献。《最后的售后》下周在《一切皆有可能》第三集中，我满载灵感回到家中。我只是觉得这是一个好主意。这一定会非常美味，我迫不及待地想尝试一下。一切皆有可能，我满载灵感回到家中。我只是觉得这是一个好主意。
This is going to be really delicious, and I can't wait to try it. And run smack into the reality of having to turn that inspiration into workable recipes. Feels like I accomplished nothing. Then later, the book enters the design phase, and I agonize over the cover, with input from Janie and the kids. I hate it. I actually hate it. Oh my god.
这一定会非常美味，我迫不及待地想尝试一下。紧接着就迎头撞上了将这种灵感转化为可执行食谱的现实。感觉我什么也没做成。随后，这本书进入了设计阶段，我在珍妮和孩子们的意见下，为封面纠结不已。我讨厌它。我其实很讨厌它。哦，天哪。
Are you serious? Special thanks to Katie Parla for showing me around Rome and schooling me on Italian history. Her most recent cookbook is Food of the Italian Islands. The Sporkful is produced by me, along with managing producer Emma Morgenstern, senior producer Andres O'Hara. Our editors on this series are Tracy Samuelson and Nora Ritchie, with editorial help from Tamika
你是认真的吗？特别感谢凯蒂·帕拉（Katie Parla）带我游览罗马并向我普及意大利历史。她最近出版的食谱是《意大利群岛的美食》（Food of the Italian Islands）。《The Sporkful》由我制作，执行制片人是艾玛·摩根斯特恩（Emma Morgenstern），高级制作人是安德雷斯·奥哈拉（Andres O'Hara）。我们这个系列的编辑是特雷西·塞缪尔森（Tracy Samuelson）和诺拉·里奇（Nora Ritchie），编辑协助来自塔米卡
Weatherspoon and Julia Russo. Our audio engineer is Jared O'Connell. Original theme music by Andrea Kristensdokter. Additional music help from Black Label Music. The Sporkful is a production of Stitcher Studios. Our executive producers are Colin Anderson and Nora Richie. Until next time, I'm Dan Pashman. And I'm Crosby from Columbus, Ohio, reminding you to eat more, eat better, and eat more better. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
韦瑟斯庞（Tamika Weatherspoon）和朱莉娅·鲁索（Julia Russo）。我们的音频工程师是贾里德·奥康奈尔（Jared O'Connell）。原创主题音乐由安德烈·克里斯滕斯多克（Andrea Kristensdokter）创作。额外的音乐协助来自黑标音乐（Black Label Music）。《The Sporkful》是Stitcher Studios出品的节目。我们的执行制片人是科林·安德森（Colin Anderson）和诺拉·里奇（Nora Richie）。下次见，我是丹·帕什曼（Dan Pashman）。我是来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的克罗斯比，提醒大家多吃点，吃得更好，吃得更好。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。